i was very attracted to her from jump
she's a
heavenly creature adam brody and
leighton meester have
always been pretty private when it comes
to their relationship
but this week the former oc star is
giving us
all the feels with a rare interview
about their love
and how they met 15 years ago the actor
opens up to anna ferris on her
unqualified podcast and reveals that he
and his now wife
first bumped into each other at cantor's
deli in los angeles around the time the
oc was wrapping up and
gossip girl had just started airing josh
schwartz produced both shows and
literally the first time we met that
whole cast was eating at cantors and i
lived at ganners for like
my entire 20s and i was leaving and he
introduced all of us
years later in 2011 the two were cast in
the romantic comedy the oranges
we like each other we did this movie
together the oranges
i was seeing someone at the time so we
met kind of through mutual work
friends off and on and then we didn't
get together until about a year after
that movie when i was single
adam reveals that he was always super
attracted to leighton but the timing
just
wasn't right i was very attracted to her
from jump she's a heavenly creature i
thought she was gorgeous and even when
we did the movie
there was like chemistry there but i was
seeing someone
and i had no idea whether she was a good
person or not and in fact
kind of assumed she probably wasn't for
like you know the first
handful years that i didn't know her
just because i don't know gossip girl
then invite strangers
i have to present myself as a crown
jewel well eventually the two started
dating they tied the knot in 2014 and
are now parents to two children and adam
admits that his initial judgment of
leighton
was way off come to find out like she's
literally joan of arc she's like the
strongest
best person i know she's my moral
compass
and north star and i just can't say
enough good things about her
character it's crazy and he wasn't
kidding
when etie caught up with a couple in
2017 they were serving lunches to
children
through feeding america the nation's
largest hunger relief organization
lending our name or face certainly
brings some level of more awareness and
that's helpful but we also need to know
what we're talking about we want to be
hands on and want to be educated and
and again like i said forge a connection
it's really nice to
get to see them one-on-one and like
actually have
contact with them and see the difference
that you know you're hopefully making
and
to be able to play and like have a good
time and they're so much fun and they're
so smart and cool
and awesome and since it was their first
time appearing in an interview together
since they said i do we just had to ask
if they've ever shared a laugh
over the fact that two of tv's most
beloved teen characters
blair waldorf and seth cohen ended up
together
irl occasionally yeah maybe occasionally
once a year once a year we have a seth
and blair day yeah
and uh i don't know it doesn't excite us
i think
because we're just human beings and i
don't know
but i mean it's exciting for a laugh
it's good for a laughs
you